i suggest you look more closely at this
no matter how many times we re-watch the
harry potter movies
there is always something new to
discover the filmmakers went above and
beyond when it came to hiding clues and
secrets within every scene
and all these years later we are still
uncovering some tiny yet incredibly
important details that have to be seen
to be believed
today we're checking out some of the
sneakiest hidden secrets from within all
of the harry potter movies
when harry first meets professor snape
snape asks him about a potion recipe
that we always assumed was a ploy to
make harry look bad in front of the
class
but actually it's so much more snape
asks harry
tell me what would i get if i added
powdered root of asparal to an infusion
of wormwood
if you don't know your victorian flowers
it's an easy message to miss
but it turns out that asphadel is
actually a lily
harry's mother and the victorian funeral
flower
and wormwood used to represent loss and
grief
after all this time always
harry first learns that his dad was a
talented quidditch captain and seeker
when hermione shows him a trophy with
his name on it in the hogwarts quidditch
trophy
case you never told me your father was a
seeker too
we almost missed another very important
name on the trophy right next to james
potter
none other than professor mcgonagall
herself
remember when neville gets a rememberall
in the mail a little magical device to
help him keep track of things
and yet i can't remember what i've
forgotten well if you look closely
neville is the only one not wearing his
robes
so we have a pretty good idea what he
needed to remember that day
did you know that the costume designers
used simple scarves to illustrate each
of the characters distinct personalities
ron's is slung carelessly around his
neck harry's is half on half off
and looks like he has been adjusting it
a lot and hermione's is perfectly and
neatly tied
of course you can also see it in their
ties how hermione's is done up properly
harry's is half undone and ron's is
almost completely off
there are so many details hidden in a
deleted scene from borgin and burke's in
the chamber of secrets
in it we see lucius and malfoy entering
the shop and they touch on quite a few
of the important items
we don't see what he is selling but
lucius takes care not to include
one unseen item in his sale that
particular item is not for sale
we later figured out that it was none
other than tom riddle's diary
that he wound up slipping to ginny in
the chamber of secrets
they used a super subtle lighting trick
in a really amazing way
when harry is first reading tom riddle's
diary before he gets pulled inside
he is lit with one candle that flickers
off of his face
once inside the diary everything
surrounding him is black and white
except for the same candle flicker
that's on him
while gilderoy lockhart had many wizards
and witches fooled
the filmmakers left a few little hints
lying around that if spotted
would make us wonder what exactly he was
hiding
one of those hints is definitely his wig
that's right right there on his desk is
a blonde wig
leading us to believe that even his
golden locks are a lie
you're a fraud you've just been taking
credit for what other wizards have done
the prisoner of azkaban is all about
time and no one knows more about time
than the legendary professor stephen
hawking
they wanted to pay tribute to him in the
movie so when harry is at the leaky
cauldron
he passes a wizard drinking a cup of tea
and reading none other than professor
hawking's book
itself a brief history of time
most of us if we were to encounter a
dragon
would be a little more worried for our
own safety than
it's the hungarian horned
but the filmmakers behind the goblet of
fire wanted to ensure
any animal lovers out there that even
mythical creatures were treated well
at the very end of the credits you can
see a disclaimer that states
no dragons were harmed in the making of
this movie
of all the subtle hints and clues hidden
in harry potter
sometimes it's clear that the designers
just wanted to have a little fun
which we noticed when we spotted the box
of cheery owls
that they stuck into the breakfast scene
in the great hall during the order of
the phoenix
looks like everyone enjoys cereal for
breakfast not just
muggles among the creepy skulls and
zombie hands in borgin and berks is one
more item that we wouldn't have paid
any attention to if it didn't come back
later in such a big way
except for the rapids do you understand
the cursed necklace that is accidentally
touched by katie bell in the half-blood
prince
is sitting on a bust inside one of the
dusty glass cases
lucky for harry he was ensnared by the
zombie hand instead
in the half blood prince we get to see
into dumbledore's memory of the first
time he met tom riddle
i'd like you to see it if you would and
in that moment
one sneaky clue tells us a lot about him
in the orphanage tom is standing next to
his window when dumbledore enters
laid out along the windowsill are seven
small rocks
which actually foreshadow his future
seven horcruxes
we often forget that lucius malfoy
actually spent some time in azkaban
after the events of the order of the
phoenix
but it's clear that he hasn't give me
the prophecy
now watch your friends
die in the deathly hallows part 2 in the
middle of the epic battle at hogwarts
when lucius reaches his arm out to his
son if you look closely
you can clearly see a tattoo of the
prisoner number that he was assigned in
azkaban written across his neck
there's one thing that muggles have over
wizards laser tattoo removal
a lot changes for the trio over the
course of the deathly hallows
but one subtle change for hermione let
us know subconsciously just how long
they had been hunting horcruxes for
if you watch closely you can see that
hermione's hair actually gets quite a
bit longer as the deathly hallows part 1
goes on
even when we thought snape had really
turned to the dark side
he was working for the order of the
phoenix the whole time
during his epic battle with professor
mcgonagall you can see him deflecting
her spells
right back at alecto and amicus the two
death eaters behind him
we may not have noticed at first but
he's actually protecting her in that
moment
during the deathly hallows part 2 right
before the battle of hogwarts
something professor slughorn did caught
our eye even though we never noticed it
before
right as all the hogwarts teachers are
making their way out of the school to
cast a protective spell
you can see slughorn taking a drink of
something in the background
it might be fire whiskey for courage but
some also think it could totally be
liquid luck
yes miss granger liquid luck
snape proved to be one of the bravest
characters in all of harry potter
during his last encounter with voldemort
snape is backed into a corner by nagini
though it's hard to tell because the
lighting is so dark if you look closely
you can see a gryffindor scarf hanging
on the wall next to him
symbolizing his bravery one of the best
reveals in all of the harry potter
movies is in the deathly hallows part 2
when we realized that voldemort hadn't
actually defeated the boy who lived
it's a triumphant moment for everyone
but if you look closely
it's also one of the most tragic when he
sees that harry is alive
george weasley looks over his shoulder
to where his brother should be
before realizing that fred isn't there
and will never be again
one more detail we never noticed is that
as harry ron and hermione slowly destroy
all of voldermort's horcruxes his robes
get progressively lighter and more faded
this was a subtle yet very effective way
to show that he himself is actually
fading away
the harry potter books and movies ended
in a much
much darker place than they began
literally
and figuratively and this transformation
is reflected in the entire tone of the
movies
including the opening titles the warner
brothers logo at the beginning of the
sorcerer's stone
is its usual bright cheerful gold but as
the movies go on it gets darker and
darker and darker with every year
and all of these are just barely
scratching the surface
if you caught any other hidden details
in the harry potter movies we would love
to hear about them
our favorite from this list is
definitely gilderoy lockhart's wig
thanks for watching